should introduce what jc is doing for
motorcycle enthusiasts
this is the 30th annual mika motorcycle
auction
happening over the next four days at the
las vegas convention center
we can certainly turn up there i guess
jason is joining us live with a look at
some of the rare rides hey j.c
yes rocky we can turn it up here and
it's actually very loud because the
auction is taking place right now
and it is so cool because there are over
1700 vintage motorcycles
up for grabs this weekend this is dave
and he's with me come auto auctions
what are some of the styles of bikes
that we're looking at that you guys have
this weekend
well as you can imagine with 700
motorcycles there's going to be a little
bit of everything no matter what your
interest is it's probably here someplace
where
we're going to have early 1900s some of
the very first motorcycles
there are some late model customs you
know beautiful
easy rider style bike here captain
america tank
yeah this is is this from the this is
just like a replica for the movie peter
finder wrote this
yeah well it's kind of a crossover
between peter fonda
and easy rider and then captain america
a little bit of both the way it's been
designed
but it's always great to come and see
some of the custom motorcycles too
a lot of stock motorcycles but there are
a lot of motorcycles here that people
put a lot of time and love
and money into developing and bring them
to the auction
so once they come down here this weekend
they can't come down as a viewer but
they can come down as a bitter how does
that work yeah because of
covet and the pandemic we're not allowed
yet to have the public
invited to our events so the event is
open only to registered bidders and
their guests
and there are still open better spots
you can come to the
convention center here walk up to bitter
registration
register you and a guest get in free for
all four days of the auction
spin around here right here look at this
crazy i got less than 30 seconds but
this is just
i could see i could see kendall tenney
kendall riding this bike
down the las vegas strip it would be
amazing real quick david what's the most
expensive bike this weekend what do you
think price range
probably the crocker big twin without a
doubt i would guess that it will be
somewhere in the 600 000 plus range
600 we've got a bike here that's worth
six hundred thousand dollars i'll tell
you what coming up in the four o'clock
hour will you show me that bike you
bet i will awesome wanna show you that
bike coming i'll even sell it to you
you'll sell it to me
kendall i need some money i gotta buy
some bikes i got you something about
yourself
we got that that's going to be fun good
to see you jc we're going to check
back in with you at 4 o'clock as well